It was,
it was an incredible,
except it's a great experience actually.
Um,
um,
I,
I sort of wandered into this,
into this business.
I'm inadvertently,
I was in the book publishing business
and,
um,
I started to publish books about
technology and about the Internet so
that I,
I was,
I,
I suppose I'm earlier than most,
um,
through this product that really had
nothing to do with the internet or
technology.
Nevertheless,
being about those subjects introduced me
to this,
to this business.
And in New York I became sort of very
early,
one of the few people who had any claim
on knowing anything about this business,
although I'd like to footnote that I
really knew nothing at all.
And um,
uh,
but as this business started to,
to um,
uh,
to heat up anybody who had any claim on
it was suddenly at the um,
um,
at center stage.
And,
um,
it was a opportunity knocking venture
capital came my way and I began to build
a company again having no idea,
um,
what kind of company I was building or
really any idea about the business in
which I was building this,
this,
um,
this company.
So this was truly learning on the job.
Um,
and,
um,
I,
I can only say in my defense that
virtually everybody who,
who was starting Internet businesses at
that point in time was also learning on
the job.
Um,
and,
um,
I,
and I,
I learned I'm not enough,
but,
um,
nobody in those days learned enough and,
everyone,
virtually everyone went under and I went
under as well.
Um,
um,
I was in the fortunate position to be
able to,
um,
to tell the story and I wrote a book
called burn rate and,
um,
and that,
which I still think as serves as one of
the great cautionary tales of,
of the period.
But,
um,
I,
I would do it again in a heartbeat.
I took certain steps when I,
when I started newser to ensure that,
um,
that,
that I,
I had gotten somewhat older and I didn't
think that I wouldn't necessarily be
able to,
my,
my system would be able to,
uh,
to tolerate the highs and lows of,
of the first experience in,
in the Internet.
So I went into newser with um,
um,
with a few safety measures.
Um,
my partner,
um,
in nooser is someone who absolutely
knows what he's doing,
who has,
um,
uh,
started two successful companies.
I'm on the Internet.
He founded hoovers.com,
hadn't took that public and then sold
it,
Dun and Bradstreet,
and he started high beam,
which I'm an another news database
company which he sold.
So I feel in a remarkably good hands,
um,
the,
the editor and chief of news there is
also,
um,
Caroline Miller,
who was the editor and chief of the New
York magazine,
credibly,
um,
professional and,
and tenacious and accomplished woman.
So in reality,
I'm at news or I do very little.